I'm unbelievably honored did I ever
think something like this would happen
no never in a thousand years
it's especially here at CMU because it's
such an extraordinary school and it's my
hometown so means a lot one of the ways
I'm involved here at CMU is through the
BTC program that my friend Ralph to show
where he he got me involved in this
program and he's a teacher here and it's
a like it's a great great program then
when I come back usually I'll do some
Q&A s or I'll discuss what's going on in
the film world of film and the truth is
when I come back they tell me what's
going on in the world of film and where
technology is taking filmmaking and
gaming and and actually it doesn't end
there it's not all about entertainment
and this is the epicenter of where most
of the stuff is really happening it's
really really exciting when you come
here and listen to these kids talk often
I think people mistakenly think of art
as some sort of supercilious thing that
is not really necessary they don't
really realize how integral it is and
how it plays a part of everyone's lives
daily really and it's really important
it doesn't it sound of a matter of I'm
looking a wonderful painting or having
access to theater it's more than that
it's more it's more of what what art in
every form every form means to society
and when you start to define things like
that and you start to lower it on the
priority list it gets very dangerous so
it's extraordinarily important
you